what's up everyone it's adam ak here for
anime lore and welcome to another
episode of rant cafe really v' and in
this episode we're gonna be discussing
recommendations anime recommendations
specifically for the fantasy genre so
our favorite anime in the fantasy genre
the best the worst and the reason that i
think this is a good topic is because i
always see a lot of comments on our
videos saying can you give me some anime
recommendations can you let me know
which anime to watch that kind of stuff
any anime similar to attack on titan
whatever so in this video what we're
gonna be doing with these read this rank
of a we're gonna do this for fantasy
we're gonna do talk about some of our
favorite fantasy anime how they're
similar to other enemy that you might
like so that you might want to check
them out we're gonna be asking people in
the chat what their favorite fantasy
anime are if you like a certain a
fantasy anime what other anime should
you check out all that type of stuff and
then if you guys enjoyed for fantasy we
might do a similar thing for other
genres in the future as well again
joining me today we got our lovely panel
and recon
no no lovely who do you have to separate
me from anime recon team including recon
he meant included Rika including yes/no
ligado NOx Taku and soul maka are here
as well as some guys oh you glad to be
here mm-hmm oh is this everything you
fantasized about mic us the topic is
fence
we get it you're hilarious thank you as
always thank you so much we already have
okay let's get into fantasy so we can
start arguing about sword on online
again we already have we already have in
the chat people I'm a hentai so I think
this is a good start
this is a great start welcome to scope
yet so haven't seen you in a while man
welcome back
and by the way by the way the anime
merch we've been selling to support a
channel has been selling quite well over
the last week so thank you everyone who
check that out really appreciate it
linking at this
if you want to see what we have to offer
and yeah who wants to start off with
some fantasy anime that you really like
or dislike that you want to either
persuade people to check out or tell
them not to check out to stay away me
made an abyss last season best anime of
the year by a longshot and it's probably
one of my favorite fantasy anime of all
time probably the top 5 for sure I still
have to finish made an abyss I watch
like the first six episodes and I
thought it was good I liked the visuals
I've definitely felt it was inspired by
like Miyazaki Studio Ghibli which I
loved but then there were some reason it
didn't while me it was kind of like that
other modern classic re-creators where I
started watching it I thought it good I
thought it was fine but I didn't it
didn't speak to me you know he didn't
force me to keep watching it for some
reason I will end up finishing though
made in an abyss because so many of you
guys have said it's good so I'm not
saying it isn't I'm definitely gonna
finish it but I just I don't like why
Knox would you really consider it such a
great anime so from the first three
episodes that's the world building was
pretty much amazing and it's gay it made
you really feel like you were part of
this fantasy world where everything you
know all society worked around this
massive chasm in the middle of their
city where they had these weird
artifacts and unexplored places and
whatever and it feels like setup all
teather aside from just being a great
universe it was also a great setup for
what could happen so let's say 3 to 9 or
3 to 8 I wasn't that excited I thought
they were whatever they were sort of
coasting off the world building they had
episodes were phenomenal
okay so then the last three episodes is
what I'm neat to watch because that's
why I'm not
kind of getting it yeah the last three
episodes were one of the most like you
know riveting emotional whatever's
really enjoyed it I have to say okay
okay so yeah that's a good tip then I
know you know how long I have to wait to
get an also I have a friend of mine
that's reading that's up-to-date in the
manga and he apparently it gets even
better
really yes I do yeah so yeah alright I
will definitely give it a chance I think
like I didn't hate it or anything like
that I was just kind of like didn't
compel me to continue but I will end up
finishing it anyone else comments I made
an abyss I actually haven't seen it
that's something that I need to check
out really bad it's the only animated
here that's worth watching excuse me
Vegas Brides overrated
oh yeah is it tell me a lie what
happened so far nothing you like are you
watching it yeah I'm up to date what
happened here is yeah tell me one thing
how the plot progress okay you were the
one who said that freaking Tuesday was
an amazing character and it only proved
throughout the series now following up
on her character build-up now you
actually know more about her you know
more about what they all about but no
what do we know more about her now from
the VIN from the end of episode 1 you
you finally know what the slay Vega is
I'm sorry I would also say buggy
yes really like that she holds a great
amount of magic if they explained so
much about it they explain that she's
going to die why Elly looks so freaking
obsessed with her and why he wants to
use her
they started explaining why all
creatures can adsorb off of her it
happened in like the second or third
episode when they went to go see the
craft lady that second episode
everything you said was in the second
episode all these things that we learned
about the slave eggie there's more
development between the relations
Elias and cheese a there somewhere was
no real development in that relationship
was there yes there is you're starting
to get a slight okay they said they said
in the last episode they called him just
a monster in human form first of all you
didn't even like now you're starting to
learn more about Elias in the new
episode before in previous episodes they
were stating like he couldn't feel what
they feel for some reason he's having a
very big protective instinct over her as
you've seen in the last two episodes so
there's so much build-up I think
happening but they're doing it so subtly
and so calming you know what I mean and
not only that you know it is like like
everybody has like a really dull voice
I'm not going to lie everybody talks
very dull you know so it may seem like
all this information isn't being blasted
in your face but it is and they're going
through the manga pretty quick they're
going through the mug at a nice decent
rate so you don't feel like it's being
dragged out for everything oh this is a
decent rate look I'm not saying I hate
it just not amazing okay so I think a
shounen fan like Knox he likes his you
know big battles and Khmer Maia's and
[ __ ] so that's why you know he can't
appreciate no Johnny but it is funny
raising ancient Magus pride but then I
ran cafe which you don't think your fans
will see you're like [ __ ] dead it's
overrated I vaguely remember making a
video on Magus Bride explaining how in
the first episode the character
development was great
and I also remember saying in my honest
descriptions that on the season that it
was very slow-moving and that the plot
didn't really develop and that it was
overrated well to be to be honest I
don't watch your videos no I'm kidding I
do but I think in terms of ancient
mangas bright there isn't that much
fast-paced action that's true but I
think that's not necessarily a bad thing
it's kind of like a more chilled out
soul I like the world-building I like
the crazy magic stuff that's good
clearly based on various mythologies
so I'm finding it you know interesting I
really like the music the vision
are amazing like the visuals aren't the
arts wonderful the world's great the
plaza this is the thing this is the
thing this is the whole entire thing
from an avid anime viewer you're going
to be looking at stuff probably
especially if you're male you're going
to be going at this and it kind of shown
in aspect to every new anime that you're
watching so you're expecting not only
you don't want your episode your
episodes dragged out but you do want
action and you do want some kind of
reveal at the end of each episode that
feels like you're giving development to
the story and the characters themselves
there's romance anime that I really like
I like lovely complex like golden time
and I think the Roman oh three that I've
mentioned was done better than the
romance aspect at least Omegas bright
they have to do it subtly because it
would level throughout the whole in kind
of subtle it's that it didn't happen
yeah it's not going that well this is
the whole entire thing you're not gonna
get the whole extra blush you're not
going to get the heart racing when they
touch each other you're not going to get
the build-up that you get a never you
know anime growth man oh my god I don't
care what I'm not getting what did I
care you trying to make it more
development was there at the end of
episode 1 he says listen girlie that
you're used to having that at the end of
each episode and this is not this is an
actual frickin build up story and it's
not going to be like every single anime
cliche are they going to put them in
there to keep anime people happy hell
yeah they are you've already seen it
throughout the episodes but they're
trying to make this more realistic you
know what I mean no I don't because I'm
trying to watch something that I want to
enjoy okay please cuz I'm getting bored
of this ok recon do you like Magus bride
I haven't even watched it not only
watches harems
no I don't watch harems I'm just I'm
just the point missing the point
compared okay petition there's a problem
right now
you both are talking me and soul doesn't
even said [ __ ] yet can we have a chance
to talk
the point is talking about ancient
Maggie's bride as a current fantasy
anime is very relevant and I think that
it is definitely a high like a
straight-up fantasy it's hot as strong
fantasy elements they're not just in the
background they're very you know
prominent in the in the show so I think
that it's a very good topic to talk
about
I don't cast her for life in the chat
said that the relationship within Elias
and she says just weird and I agree a
hundred percent I don't get any romance
from this relationship for something but
he's also kind of like obviously he has
some compassion for her as a creature a
living creature that's been unfortunate
she why would she feel any romance
towards him other than she feels
worthless in her life he's finally
treating her like a human being so she's
grateful but that's not romantic to me
there's no romance there and if they did
have romance at this point that would be
completely completely contrived well I'm
going to be honest the romance doesn't
start building up in the manga until way
later on and the reason for them doing
this is because he got cheese a when she
was pretty young and as she starts aging
and becoming into a woman then he starts
also realizing and developing that he's
not what he think he he is I'm not
trying to get away spoilers you know but
look I don't want to discuss that even
really right now for the six six or
seven episodes that aired already III
don't see the appeal that much I like it
it's not only gonna like it beautiful
art great fantasy whatever I'm I'm not
overly impressed by it well that's okay
you don't have to eat its overly
impressed I'm I'm not overly impressed
by a lot of stuff that other people are
all really impressed by but I think that
it's definitely something I'm giving us
a chance to also Knox you're wrong when
you say stuff
like the only animal of this year worth
watching is made an abyss I don't know
what your standard oh not only grilling
I'll suddenly are however there's really
fun animal there like I keep saying Garo
vanishing line is it's not a some kind
of philosophical masterpiece but it's a
really fun action anime that I enjoy and
look forward to watching
and unlike maiden abyss I keep watching
it because it actually draws me in and
it's entertaining Oh didn't work for me
like I like I think that for made an
abyss it's kind of has the same effect
on me as if Magus bright has for you
it's good art and all that stuff but the
story doesn't draw me in like why is
this well I didn't do actual Garr guides
adult guides allow her to enter the
abyss with some robot that no one knows
what he is like that that's bad plot
that's it you want me to defend the
block well it's just that what you're
asking just ran away it would have been
one thing but she had actually did run
away or her in doing this sound
supporter she did run away no decide an
adult guy helps her escape yeah the
black whistle guy remember with the bed
he's like her father something napped I
don't know observation woman she's a
psycho observation woman and he didn't
get there yet
I'm not talking about ozan Oh see this
is why nuts gets triggered when I point
out flaws and his stuff he likes what he
likes to point out flaws and other
things interesting interesting flaws you
pointed out I just told you an adult an
adult planet which do you see the show
there's only one black whistle guy
that's because he's apparently like her
Godfather or something that would make
it even less likely for him to want to
put her in danger
has what kind of weapon no a laser
blaster won't finish it all ended all
sewn up did you like it yeah loved it
can't wait for next season also looks
damn again you agree I know this is not
good this is not good the other thing is
the guy the guy who runs the orphanage
clearly could have stopped her but
didn't so that's a second adult do you
have company like he gave him a head
start even though he gonna happen gay
bridge - no remember saying that oh yeah
you go like 24 hours I'm coming for you
in the morning
yes I will take your resignation now max
thank you he's basically he's testing
her on a Mac he's testing away in the
chat Opie trevor has really been wanting
to talk about the seven deadly sins
fantasy anyway that's coming next season
winter 2018 a lot of hype around that
anime so definitely we can talk about
that has everyone here seen seven deadly
sins yeah what I've always seen two
episodes you shouldn't really talk about
them okay that's major spoilers no we
can talk about okay seven deadly sins is
an adventure anime that's not like your
average Shonen the characters the main
cast are overpowered and even well for
overpowered carriage burn let his best
girl write that didn't really spoil much
did it say that NOx because I know soul
maka things that sound of these sins is
just like every other shown and it's
that it's very generic meanwhile I
definitely like seven deadly sins for
its characters in terms of like the
powers the power scaling all of that
stuff doesn't make sense a lot of it is
just like seems like hospitals in many
cases yeah for sure
it's a fun cast and they're having a fun
time adventuring in a fun scenario where
they're going to save country or
whatever so it doesn't matter what I
heard it's also pretty I heard it was
like really funny like I heard it was
hilarious and there's fun of other anime
about that but there's good humor in
there I don't know I liked it I enjoyed
it not for anything deep but at least
it's not your you know protagonist with
no powers that gets powers that becomes
the wizard King Ninja Lord Hokage basic
crybaby underdog becomes the you know
the greatest right now the two things
about seven of these sins that I think
are really its strong suits are a the
character is being really interesting
and fun and relatable and you you know
you like then there's and not just the
main character but like several
characters are really cool and the
strong humor aspect to it so there's a
strong humor aspect to it in this so
like like Knox says I personally would
not call you know enjoy it on like some
kind of deep level but from being just a
fun funny anime with interesting
characters a hundred percent I'm enjoy
it quite a bit I mean there are they're
[ __ ] also I mean there's this you
know there's little [ __ ] guy turns out
through the massive night guy who's like
an undead fairy who turned out to be
like some reanimated whatever I mean
there are issues with the show too but
in all it's a good time and it knows
that it's just there to be a good time
and that's really nice it's not trying
to be melodramatic yeah well I could say
the same thing about fairy tale oh well
you want to talk about fairy tale it's a
fantasy I'm just saying I could say the
same thing about very toe well except
fairy tale okay no I'm just saying the
same things you said which were the good
points are the same things well I think
they're done better in seven deadly sins
although you're right that
is the enjoyable aspect to fairytale the
familial parts ow
the guild operates is really fun I like
that I really like the grand magic games
I thought it was really fun hmm but what
would be the thing is no yeah now the
thing is with fairy tale is that it went
on for a much longer period of time
whereas seven deadly sins has only had
one season so you could say that you
know seven deadly sins might go in the
same direction as fairy tale as they
have to produce more and more material
and lose its charm right because it's
still early so it's kind of hard to
compare the two but in the in the early
episodes I felt fairy tale had a lot of
humor as well it was quite entertaining
- wouldn't you say well I didn't I don't
know I liked my favorite parts of fairy
tale were the parts between the arcs
like there were the massive story arcs
where you have your six main good guys
or your four main good guys that go in
each main good guy fights a main bad guy
of that arc winds turns that bad guy
good and then not to gets a crazy power
up either he eats mr. Nana or golden
flames or whatever the hell beats the
main bad guy and that's the arc right
half the bad guys become good the other
half are in jail well not so was
fighting the Dragons when the Dragons
were attacking that was pretty dark that
was really good arc well I like that
well that was sort of right after the
grand magic games yes it was so I like
the grand magic games just because
that's the fun part of fairy tale that I
like I don't like the dramatic parts -
fairy tale because I think it sucks at
them but no really yeah
no no yeah no every bad guy becomes good
why why does every bad guy become good
here's the if you can't beat them you
join them that's the only one bad guy it
can stay bad tell me one better bad guys
I don't think why them guys so yeah they
turned to good because they said to
themselves if I can't beat them I'll
just join them so yeah that's that's
what they did
look buddy bad not it either no one died
and no one became no one stayed
hello what's going on no no one has to
die no Matt Matt the storytelling
pointed out that in both fairy tale and
seven deadly sins no one really seems to
die so that is a good at least bad guys
die in seven deadly sins oh very good
they just assimilate what no you tell me
all the bad guys in fairy tale turn good
is that were you saying every single bad
guy in fairy tales and let it set unless
they're like a demon or some Buddhist
the words left your mouth yeah and such
and so suddenly not all bad guys stay
alive almost every bad guys a human it's
like happens do you see how that happens
no not all the bad guys are human there
are also dragon bad guys Oh dragon that
guys there was one dragon bad guy yeah
and he stayed bad you didn't know that
you didn't read the manga yet you don't
know what's gonna happen to ACMA logia
yeah I know
pretty sure he's okay we can't shut down
at recon why you tell me down so you got
shut down because you you try to say
something and knocks got you with the
[ __ ] I always do to him with my
arrogance but who cares about the
[ __ ] manga well that's the manga is
the can and that's the most important
thing that's the source material the
manga is the source muscle you're
telling me knucks has also read the
manga is that correct
Nux knows enough not to expect anything
from fairytale or
gromek said that i [ __ ] all over Naruto
for no one dying in there you must be
confused someone else because I didn't
even see that much of Naruto to be able
to [ __ ] a lot of people died not enough
not nearly enough but I don't want to
list them just spoilers but lots of
people died that's a double folks claim
right there I'll tell you okay look no
no not you the person who made the
comment cuz never talks about he doesn't
talk about what he doesn't know it's
very important right regardin yeah yeah
sure take take or Casper says has anyone
seen Allah in the sea I have very
interesting fantasy anime I thought the
first season was a bit slow but then
their second season gets really good so
I personally enjoyed that animates one
of those kind of like the ancient
magazines in the sense that it's kind of
you know slow-paced you got to kind of
take it in so it's like a slice of life
slash magic anime a lot of heavily based
on like Japanese mythology and yeah
overall I enjoyed it even though the
first season was a bit slow for me I
don't know if anyone else has seen it
it's also known as Nagi soo no yes the
other manga I told watch the anime but
yeah that was a good anime for me though
the one girl got chose in the end but
that's all I have to say about you
talking about knocking off Sakura yeah
yeah oh yeah that one is very good sure
I like that yeah yeah but one girl got
chosen the end yeah I know one I would
recommend to people is you to worry mono
episodes right I think I dropped it yeah
yeah it's decent for me not the best oh
I know sign in doing it so no yeah
how about we talk about the best fantasy
anime of all time the best Maggie no not
Molly
no not high school how do i School DxD
is mostly a harem the best please no
mines not fantasy yes it is yes
technically sword art online is sci-fi
with fantasy elements a bad fantasy
would be wolf
knocks knocks chilled knocks chill bro
no not all are you gonna say when I
looked up fantasy anime for this year
sword art online was like in the top
three I'm sorry to animate but you just
know because he just said that sao is
not a fantasy SEO is not a fantasy
elements I do agree with him on there it
is sci-fi but it has fantasy elements
because it's such a popular show it's
gonna be on the top of list recon you
first of all nice comeback
second of all here's the thing is that
there are a lot of anime that have
elements of sci-fi and fantasy use the
reason that sword are online is
technically sci-fi is because everything
is happening in a game for which you
need technology futuristic technology to
access the web what do you mean it's a
fantasy game so in that sense it has
aspects of fantasy do you understand yes
I do understand but it still it takes
place in a fantasy game so it's already
oh yeah so it's not if there was it
doesn't really have to relate to life
there was a high school Roman
and one guy has a dream where he's
slaying a dragon is it a fantasy anime
dream then yeah yeah yeah so it now it's
a crucial fantasy elements are crucial
in storyline
anyway doesn't matter we can talk about
sort of the line if you guys want but I
do want to point out that there's people
people that well people in the child
have pointed this out as well that you
know there's anime like Code Geass which
has fantasy elements and a lot of sci-fi
elements like mecca's right and there's
a bunch of anime like that where there's
a lot of like a lot of fantasy but also
a lot of sci-fi and it's like almost
sometimes even match sometimes more
sci-fi but with a hint of fantasy
another popular thing has been mentioned
in the chat is fate so you're Maggie
damn you get five five five we'll talk
about but faith series personally I
liked fate zero and unlimited blade
works but I did not like Apocrypha at
all so yeah I like I'm not like a fait
series fan but I like some of it but I'm
not like anything fade I'm like yes
I don't know so for me I didn't really
like unlimited blade works to be honest
animation was nice but like the plot was
men the characters were fair but I liked
fate/zero
very much me faint for me is soy's being
that the highlight is the servants and
that's the focus and that's all it is
it's like fanservice of servants
what about Apocrypha no one likes
Apocrypha Studio Ghibli movie oh yeah no
I love I love Ghibli so much oh no no
that's poncho but it is like a new
Ghibli like Ghibli 2.0 but that's
actually studio control I haven't seen
it it's a good I don't know I wanna see
it I really want to see it new way of
like cutting down the time to make a
movie cuz
they take like four years this one they
didn't I think it was two so I wanna see
like how well going forward how well it
can do as you know as it saves time it
means you know they can make more moon
yeah that's amazing idea yeah a lot of
people to have an attack on Titan in the
chat that's one of those again where
it's like I feel both fantasy and sci-fi
because I think a lot more friend well I
think action
I think action fantasy more than
anything yeah I don't really see any
sci-fi in there and because that's
because you don't read the manga and you
don't watch my video for [ __ ] sake
yeah don't talk just recon don't talk
man uninformed your app you rant café's
we're all just gonna be sitting here
like sheep and anime is gonna like recon
is just off his ass because he doesn t
talking to make an opinion the reason
why I didn't watch your attack on Titan
videos because you talked about the
manga man like you can't talk no you're
limited by the fact that you don't know
so if they don't pretend like you know
if you don't know just say guys I don't
know this is what I think they're like
oh no it's not guys and it's like what
bro you don't know the story oh is that
I have a theory that a lot of attack on
Titan stuff is supposed to be sci-fi but
not realistic sci-fi but an aspect of
sci-fi so it's nowhere okay please rage
your side so I need to be where the
sci-fi an attack on time please buddy
can all be man-made that's really saying
it's the end of the day recon there's a
thing called Titan science so for once
the word science is using them become
scientific which then
turns it into sci-fi oh I'm gonna
respect you that your opinion guys don't
worry yes my opinion of what I've read
in the chapters of the manga Deku is
stronger than all might that's my
opinion that's what that came out of
left field in my yeah
opinions are what and my opinion all
might died at the end of the first
season what okay they're great if they
go against the source material it's a
nice way to say I don't know what's
happening but okay listen any of you
guys seen tower of druaga no yeah I
followed bring us back on topic before
selling out starts crying
no sorry weather like one fantasy n I
mean I was wanted to get into that I
never started was not to make Jin show
soul you must have watched it no yes I
did yes I really loved that one that one
was like like sixty now yeah yeah yeah
he's grandma owned this like book diary
yeah and basically she she could see
spirits in it so what she used to do she
used to get rid of the spirits in it you
know they were troubling people's think
of her like an exorcist but your
friendly neighborhood Exorcist and what
you do is she would challenge the
spirits to like some type of game or
some kind of you know challenge and then
when she defeated them she would then
seal them in the book oh so basically is
now the the grandson I made our new life
main hurt
he's now inherited this book and
basically a lot of the spirits are
coming to him because they're like oh we
want our soul back
give us household back here so I'm
trying to attack him he's then got
another spirit that's trying to defend
him because it says from the first
episode it wants to
get the book back you it wants him to
like release all the souls so it can
take the book back in devour his soul
instead so it's basically protecting him
from others because it wants to eat him
kind of reminds me of that was it
Tora Russia oh no Tora oh yeah no that
but not as kiddy with the set up in it
it feels more silent and then yeah
basically you you're having like
adventures in like these heat like
couple episodes of the encounter with
said spirit one in their soul back and
then some kind of challenge or some kind
of thing needs to help them like a
system with you know to like so I heard
great things about NASA made ginger yeah
is good is good is good okay so I feel
like thank you soul for that like calm
conversation I feel like no one has
gotten triggered in like two minutes so
can we talk about another good anime
raring this season that's magic I love
about black Cobra perfection in its
writing like they know exactly what
they're doing I don't think there was a
wasted whenever Sun comes out shitty
yeah for some reason they knew what they
were doing they did it on purpose
they're geniuses so they must have done
it on purpose you know the best part is
the three minute recap at the beginning
of each episode understand the stories
every week yeah I would say just like
the five minute like catch up on every
episode of one piece yeah well you do
that the reason they do that is because
they got 50 episodes and fill the [ __ ]
up hey Dave did the mental age of a
six-year-old actually I actually um
there are arcs parts of the arcs when
[ __ ] gets serious
and they don't do the recaps like I mean
they do do it but it's like for like two
minutes and then they start flowing into
that what's actually happening now and
then they show the intro and they just
go off right away and they try to almost
make it like a how would you say it like
today's kind of sitcoms or series that
you see on television they try to do it
like that for a little bit Macha can ask
you a question if you'd have tried as
hard as you can and could would you have
been able to adapt black clover as badly
I don't think so he hasn't even answered
you so bunny first of all you going on
is if the source material is actually
good the point is that every question
the Knux asks is rhetorical you guys
should know that by now but the second
thing is I'm enjoying black clover for
what it is for now I might get bored of
it I don't know what I'm enjoying for
what it is for now I don't care what you
guys say but not yeah Knox since I know
you're waiting for it why don't we talk
about moggy I didn't want to talk about
my no I want to talk about moggy
minority you didn't you say the poet
Nagi is like a better version of black
clover like uh but like an actual good
magic show so there's a recommendation
saying for people who might be
disappointed black clover or even who
like it you would tell them to check out
my I wouldn't really say Maggie has
anything to do with black closer be
honest black cloak again Bonin's or even
fantasies yeah well I will get shonan's
or even fantasies like we put it in two
categories one is underdog protagonist
trying to get somewhere and like the
other one is everything else like it's
hard for me to even consider you know
Naruto and whatever my hero academia and
black clover it's hard to put that in
the group of seven deadly sins and
Maggie and whatever
it's a fantasy but it's not the same
angle as every other one about you queue
holder then what about it oh you can
show it holder yeah it's nothing amazing
it's not terrible
very good Harry so what do you think is
bad that I'm talking about the new uq
holder UQ holder has this one genderless
creature yes I know there is also a guy
dressed as a girl I know that he is that
that person is not male or female
yes so he's other yeah he's out there
exactly yeah
fantastic yeah that's great
the monkey watches Sinbad no bouken
swallow I suggest you actually watch it
in order that's a crazy idea or what
senpai my bucket isn't even related to
the other monkey so you can wash it home
free honestly you should watch every
second episode like watch 1 3 then go
back to 2 for constant yelling this
microphone is right I think about moggy
you should watch it in order and then
bodies am into it I mean you could watch
it out of order but why now be stupid
right but they're related but the
stories are not even related so but if
you know Sinbad already from the
original Maggie it actually means
something instead of being a stupid
overpowered protagonist he is ladies
next up first of all Maggie I'm enjoying
seeing him in this childhood some Andes
and no prosecuted and [ __ ] with
everything that's going on like pretty
entertaining
Josh stuff they really want to wants to
talk about Duff Duff piece one piece
aka selfies from now on and Knox since I
know you want to talk about I know now I
is really into one piece now why don't
you guys take it away well now you are
an amazing
no noxee in minutes yes start now room
now well now it's amazing but wait what
next is probably going to say is that
better I agree and also since this is
about recommendations you can give some
recommendations for people who enjoy one
piece what else might they enjoy to read
the one piece manga because the anime is
cutting out is one thing the other
family always the hosing oh my heart's
great yeah you know like I was I just
started recently reading a manga and I'm
shocked yeah where are you up to I just
got done with a couple chapters like I
just recently started reading the manga
but I'm on like I'm almost episode 300
and the one piece anime series so you
didn't even start water seven oh no I
haven't yet
around there but I am I just
what am I on right now right now oh
right now who stops goose up left and
right now he's trying to defend that
he's this [ __ ] superhero the way just
fun prank now one of the good episodes
in the anime the you saw versus Luffy
fight I cried so bad I cried so much
throughout this series like you actually
get your feelings invest a lot actually
there are a lot of moments that bring
you to that point
oh my god it's bad it's almost like
every single time there's a new crew
member that's gonna join you know you're
gonna [ __ ] cry or if you know
somebody's been there for a while and
they're going you're gonna [ __ ] cry
who watches battle shown and to cry and
get emotional there's this issue anime
you somehow don't realize that some
battle shonan's are good you only watch
the bad ones so you wouldn't know
this would appear so if somebody dies or
they leave or something dramatic happens
you're so invested into the story
because you're 200 or 50 episodes in or
you just something's building up inside
that you can't help but tear up a little
bit not why almonds you realize you were
just saying that the one-piece anime
isn't that good especially compared to
the manga and now you're telling me that
I should watch one piece because it's so
good
obviously I'm gonna get into one piece
of you gonna read the manga yeah read
the money I didn't don't have to watch
it you can read it because with all
these as we know with all these
long-running Shonen they want it they're
very popular right so they want to make
more episodes not less so it's when a
season has 50 episodes instead of 25 or
13 they're gonna have a lot of filler
they're gonna have a lot of recaps right
so that's why if you really want to
catch up on stuff and if the manga
doesn't trail off like the original full
metal alchemist if it actually follows
the story the anime keeps following the
manga then read the manga catch up that
way I think that is a very good
suggestion for everyone so as we're
talking hunter hunter for example which
madhouse did a great job on the manga
starting again in 2018 actually they do
10 chapters and they go on shown in
trash shown in trash
okay recon I'm gonna it's a great great
mantra but you do it somewhere else
recon I'm gonna stop you honestly like
if you haven't seen something stop
commenting on it if you don't need to
know everything you haven't seen you
haven't seen a lot of stuff maybe I
should say like not show to trash I'm
like this is the Analects fairy tale oh
yeah look we're talking about showing
all the content I'm okay so what do you
want to talk about mister fairy tale and
sword art online please tell me
something else besides Shawnee
don't end that you like go ahead kono
super and breezy roe what flap yourself
[ __ ] you man no it's cool kono super
Andrew zero both good fantasy anime yeah
let's talk about them come on now that
shows recon so that those are anime we
can't talk about but you don't have to
freak out about it um also some people
the Chad mentioned Death Note
that is a very good mature fantasy anime
a hundred percent agree that's no really
good a lot of a lot of Full Metal
Alchemist Brotherhood obviously alchemy
is type of magic type of fantasy so yeah
definitely a lot of more mature and I'm
out there that are magic o mushishi
definitely not a shounen but a great
anime that i really enjoy some people
find a mooring because it's so
fast-paced and episodic but I really
enjoy it I think it's like a really cool
experience it makes you kind of connect
with nature and the mythology of ancient
you don't like Boulder Japan and stuff
like that so yeah enjoyed greatly but
okay what do we what do we do ba and so
Ron's line other than that's what our
life easier
other than our easy row we still don't
know if there's gonna be a second season
or when with kono Suba a new anime
project was announced but key word
project we don't know if it's actual
season if it's gonna be a movie like no
game no life we're not sure so yeah go
ahead guys I think no BA actually sure
it's an OVA yeah I mean yeah I think so
I think my anime list came out with
something like that saying it was an OVA
but I'm not a hundred percent on that so
don't quote me last time I checked and I
try to follow the news regularly but
last time I checked anyways zoo project
called a tsuba is probably one of the
funniest animator and watched probably
one of the best comedy I've ever seen so
yeah that's that's me for chroma super
it's it's funny as [ __ ] I almost like
every single episode at most cases and I
can't stop saying how much aqua has such
a useless goddess and how much I love
mega mean because she explodes and just
collapses
and I stole I don't really like darkness
I mean so yeah except for the one
episode where the giant just played with
her boobs you know as it was jiggling up
and down yeah that's about it the Recon
monologues Rika says something I agree
with that he likes called a tsuba
but his reasons are so nonsensical and
random what did you really make under me
because she's exploding what kind of
rationale is that for anything because
it's because it's funny
got a facepalm for a while guys if
knocks anyone else want to say anything
I want to watch you facepalm be honest
you don't have a sense of humor adamak
joy
kono Suba but I enjoy the humor not just
the explosions that's one that's one guy
you don't know is my favorite character
from from kasuba
we know so yeah I look beggining my
favorite character from consumer that's
favorite female character from Kona
super to be honest yeah a lot of
agreement between NOx and recon for
totally different reasons
what is your reason for liking mega mean
please tell me why are we doing Mega Man
again we've done this like six times
ready well I just have to say I am
actually surprised that none of you even
though I didn't like the anime version I
am actually surprised that none of you
mentioned yojo Sankey oh you only yeah I
wasn't amazing I don't think we would
mention it it wasn't bad wow I always
hear people going off on it no I didn't
hear anyone going off about it I know
you have a lolly youkai Nazi and that's
it that's so then you know did you pro
was loving it
digi bra was in seventh heaven pedantic
romantic he was able to put her a bloody
face on the front of all of his
thumbnails but see this is bloody lolly
faces man like everyone was having a
great time yes I I heard good things
about your just think he from a lot of
critics and to me it was just solid kind
of like recreated read nothing that
nothing nothing that like grab meets
like whoa this is something I'll
remember but it was like not bad right
so that's kind of my take on I must
referred it to recreate errs to be
honest and actually kept me watching it
the whole way through which is
mind-blowing three creators is sort of
didn't yeah I agree with you Knox I also
am one of those people that recreate
errs I got in like twelve episodes in
and I was kind of like I dropped a box
on fourteen tongue is freaking Jojo
sanke on the Tanya yeah I freaking loved
that series I'm like sitting here
thinking about like why is that sounds
so familiar I think I seen that series I
just typed in them like oh I love that
that was a really really good series
that was really good pretty sure we'll
have a second season because it left off
open oh god dad I love that that was a
really good one
that was good I think it was like I feel
like it didn't get a good like you know
what I mean hype that I feel it deserved
I didn't buy pretty sure garlic oil or
eight point something operating on my
animalist I just feel like I didn't hear
a lot of people talking about it when it
was like you know what I mean not as
much as like other series that were out
around that time it's hard for the
business community it's hard to talk
about current anime because unless it's
a really hyped one you don't get views I
mean I sort of know from experience as
this anime
no one else really does that type of
thing but unless it's a really hyped
anime like
my hero academia got you views pretty
much nothing else gets you booze unless
you're pathetic romantic and you have a
bloody lolly face on the club nail
that's why he got four hundred fifty
thousand views on his euro thank you
video but aside from that it's really
hard like my Magus bride video only got
somewhere in the teen thousands that's
not crazy yeah by me yeah in terms of
hype like nice in terms of hype it's
hard to really gauge it because as
members of the anime economy like
there's certain people you subscribe to
so even though you know maybe I have a
lot of people talking about Tonya the
evil that I follow in the anime world
because you know in the end of the world
it's interesting
lolly Nazi whatever like it's an in it's
like an interesting premise but you you
could be right that you know in the
wider community outside of YouTube
there's not that many people talking
about it right so it's like you know how
do you gauge the hype I don't know
problem like maybe if Netflix has an
animating you can see how many people
actually watched it by their stats or
something like that but it's hard cuz
we're immersed within a community where
we're kind of more sensitive to
everything then like for example
audience mm-hmm like the current airing
anime and as it is unless it's a crazy
hyped one that people were waiting for
it doesn't really get anywhere there's
like one a year that really blows up
that types for everyone attack on Titan
sorted online Tokyo ghoul was like that
one punch man was like that those are
like big names that even at the time
were hyped everything else is pretty
much not well we have and because
because with all my fancy
recommendations we have two sequels that
have some type coming up next season
seven of these since we talked about it
for stop also overlord which goes from a
sci-fi to a fantasy straight out to like
an ISA Kai so those two I feel like have
some hype do they have not attack on
Titan my uremia hide what they do have
some light can you think of any other
coming up my 18 that are not so bad is
the anime coming next season that I'm
looking forward to most more than both
of those is psyche psyche Cousteau now
seen on
because no one watches good anime please
don't
he's been bugging him like crazy
apparently he's on your discord server
and he found me there and he's like
trying to get me to buy his book oh
that's just what he does but he's fans
me you can't take that personal it's not
personal I just in the previous stream
yeah very satchel I did cry in the end
yes
yeah it's emotional yeah I haven't seen
but psyches really good and some people
pick up no one watches psyche because
when it aired last year 2016 the first
season it was it aired every weekday one
episode and each episode was like four
minutes long when on the English dub
they combined them into 20-minute
episodes which is useful right because
when it's a different format it's heart
with that one anime that did have quite
a bit of hype I think that's unusual for
like a non shown in mainstream anime was
Ruiz ero I thought we zero definitely
had quite a bit of hype a yeah that did
happen not not like mine here I could a
Mia blow up a bill a pipe because of REM
yes yeah boy yes girl if you have memes
like same thing with kono Suba kono Suba
hat hype because of the means that come
out of this show look at blend yes this
season oh my god the opening meme of
blend s am i the only one that is such a
good series towards the end like I feel
like Rijo should have ended like right
when the creature popped up at that one
final episode and cut off his head when
he was holding REM
should I end it right there yeah that
would that would be great
no it would have been amazing because
that was you know then it turns high
like three zero I know it has flaws like
an abyss has flaws but it was a really
good I just didn't like no one's Emilia
come on guys I loved her first I'll
answer it why do you do this I clearly
explained that Emilia is the bet the
better character in that playing hi
she's not look I think I answered
anytime's question very well yeah who
are you have you seen this magic spell
die magic spell die magic spell live
heal west of my name explain - don't
hear what you were talking about so
marker because that's what we need it
for sure yeah what are you talking okay
I was talking hot okay no one interrupts
me now because it's very clear what
Amelia did Amelia a saved what was his
name Subarus life in the very first
episode before she even knew him and
gave up her medallion thing that was
important to her because because she's a
good person her whole goal is to help
other people including people have been
discriminated all their lives for no
reason like her because she's a good
person
when suberin stock starts acting like a
stalker creepy maniac she tells him stop
it and [ __ ] off because she knows what
she's doing and she's a strong character
unlike REM who first of all attacks uber
and kills them for no reason miss
understand away with the dumbest recover
because
worthless character those last two
points were false one she got wind of
subbu subbu was jeopardizing her chances
at the crown okay
he wasn't talking her and he creepy not
justice to REM kill him because she
believed he was a spy of the witch
because in their world which is bad
smells like the witch and he had to
which his scent
bro just because doesn't meet that I
should look just just to come back here
for a second I
when recon asked me do I like Rama yeah
I pretty much I remember saying I don't
like Amelia I like you a red person
either of the two are great characters
I think REM was a lot cooler because she
had a big mystery behind her and then
you saw this might be heard in take
learn how it changed I really like if I
had to pick a preference between the two
of them I'm I guess I'd say REM but not
because she's a great character if you
were me anyway the point is we're gonna
wrap it up soon but REM is your classic
otaku bait contrived character oh I'm
emotionally unstable I have a difficult
past I'll do I'll fall in love with this
guy do whatever he says because I'm
passive and I'll just protect him and do
everything for him
complete otaku bait not a complete
character
unlike Amelia who is actually her own
person and an interesting character and
actually wants super to be a better
person doesn't indulge his stupidity so
yes thank you very much Amelia best girl
web muscle left woodsy cuz she and
autism whole entire series you knew who
she was
that's what made her cool so I'm not I'm
definitely not disagreeing with you on
that part but I also agree in the part
that I feel he should have frickin chose
Ren that's actually why I didn't like
the series is because he didn't choose
her and the whole factor that was is
because I thought she was this person
that had evil intent and then throughout
the series she developed into that Chaka
crazy thing I think it was 23 or 24 with
that long-ass dialogue for ramen sugru
ended the episode
no doubt episode 18 I was 18 yeah long
ass dialogue and at the end he just says
he loves Amelie that really say it again
a contrived tragic past does not equal
character development okay
that was huge caramel jalapenos know how
she changed it was the fact that she was
this person that was evil and had evil
intent and then she changed into that
otaku crazed person not even until
halfway through the series you know what
I mean and then towards the end like
towards like that half of the rest of it
you know towards the end you started
realizing like she is in love with him
she will do anything for him is so and
it was something that you didn't expect
for rent
so that is billion did any of that [ __ ]
no I don't think he was the same about
the whole series until you figured out
more resent like alignment with the
witch and then she kind of changed into
even more kind of serious tone person
but either way she did stay true blue to
what she is and that's why I think she
was a cool character but I feel he
should've chose around because she you
totally didn't see that [ __ ] coming
you think he's obsessed with her so how
crazy would have been if you drop it all
at the last second for the demon girl
gorgeous grenade things just because
just because development just because
Emilia is a complete character at the
start and not a completely dependent
cycle doesn't make her a bad character
like just because they don't develop her
as we go and she's already somewhat a
development that's not a bad thing no
that's what people fall for these cliche
tropes obvious if super wanted to be
with Ram to be stay the obsessive [ __ ]
that he was the reason he wants to be
with the media because he knows that
Emilia will make him a better man
because she actually expects things
from him doesn't just indulge his
stupidity sorry Grammy yeah if you want
it to be a better person if you want to
stay even with you you can't do with
people the first episode Emilia risks
everything to save a complete stranger
because you didn't that person will then
turn around and say what is Emilia I
ever done like you can't argue with
these people you can do it so knocks no
idea what you're talking about
just be frank she did we were amazing
Emilia was okay Ram was fine moving on
Mac says in the chat one of my favorite
fantasy anime of all time he says what
about drama alert I call it fantasy
because keemstar makes up 80% of what's
on that thing that new talk about drama
alert or Kim the douchebag
please the point is that people who said
Cory in the house cory in the house is a
slice-of-life anime not a fantasy so
yeah get your [ __ ] together guys anyhow
in a broom it's time to wrap this up
before I freak out on recon again and
potentially nuts look what I even go on
my army list and type in Cory in the
house it doesn't appear in their recon
you tell us who you are what you do and
what one fantasy anime you would
recommend to everyone to watch what's
the boys your boy recon and I do them
top 10 anime lists and I recommend you
all to watch SEO fairy tale one I said
one Oh
just watch si oh yeah okay you all
watched it though he's not being ironic
everybody in case you're wondering now I
got up do you
yes I'm now a god oh I do funny Anime
News and soon animations and I recommend
you all to watch ancient mega spread
nice thank you
knocks Taku senpai
what animat Koha I know I'm also the
both temp eyes to each other yes I
didn't realize anyway onto fantasy
recommendations so I'll recommend one
that we didn't talk about until here
spice and wolf is my favorite romance
anime and it is also a fantasy anime
good recommendation knocks you went for
the little older and I love spicy wolf
so I guess Rika does like spice mole so
that's interesting
recently he's been trying to say he
likes everything I like mrs. Ben no I'm
serious a [ __ ] watched spice and wolf
why so wolf is really damn good Thank
You Knox so maka to you hey everyone so
I recommend everyone should check out
Tom a yokai is a cool
that's a nice cute romance fantasy anime
I want to say that again slower you say
it again slower did you not get that
look I didn't get it at all
Oh Tomoko Makai suru otome a yokai is a
cool okay
you gotta got it got it you too man
yeah 13 episodes long nice little
fantasy romance freedom 7.5 on my anime
list good good
worth watching yeah okay thank you soul
and for me I would recommend everyone
watch mushishi now I know a lot of
people won't like it but to me it's very
special
really good anime one of those that I
always remember so that would be my
recommendation by the way everyone's
channel links are in the description
thank you for joining us we're for a
stream where recommendation of a fancy
anime turned into violent rants about
white booze and recons tastes well
that's every rank of Fae really let's
face it thanks guys
three otherwise known as recon
strangling of the week like oh it's true
if you think about it at every rank of a
we end up complaining about white booze
in some way and about recons taste in
some ways so that is we've had worse
we've had worse the worst one when we
actually had a stream on black critic
guy's channel an entire two-hour stream
talking about REM versus Amelia oh my
god that without was rehab moments trust
me this actually happened white
supremacist last week sort of past
updated version of members Amelia but
that with the orange rocks Taku all the
right people like black clover so you
know and in my opinion everyone who
thinks that Ram is best girl is a
communist thank you guys